formulas have a really bad name formulas
are what a lot of people hate about
mathematics because it's just memorizing
you know these weird arcane things and
then just putting numbers into them you
feel like a computer because that's what
computers do right that's what we have
them but I'd like to try and convince
you formulas formulas are brilliant
because what they do and process it
which requires lots of intense thought
and concentration and they make them
almost automatic they just make it
simple to solve okay exit life which are
you had a formula for them it'll be
great it's just like okay I just do this
this this and it out comes the answer
right well that's what we've designed
devised for quadratics so underneath
your little subheading right this what
this is is well clearly it's a quadratic
equation just like we've been looking at
right but what I've put up rules to
indicate these could be eighty numbers
right they could be one Nick one at
negative three or they at negative one
or they could be five a hundred and
whatever you like okay so a B and C a B
is any numbers so if they are any
numbers then this quadratic equation is
any quadratic or another way of thinking
about it is it's every quadratic that
ever exists depending on what you want a
B and C to do okay by the way a B and C
they're also given other names they're
called coefficients because they sit in
front of these variables okay so hey
guys there's a quadratic have a great
thing with this is even though I don't
know what a B and C are the great power
of algebra is you can work with numbers
even when you don't know what their
values are right so see in all these
cases we know what the numbers are but
here if I can give these numbers that I
don't know if I could give them names I
can work with me right in fact with this
I can just like I've been doing already
just like you could do you I can
complete the square right I'm gonna take
this guy
and I'm going to complete the square now
even though I don't know what any other
numbers are right so we need to do a few
things you have a look at us completing
the square excuse me these other
questions right the first thing I need
is completing the square only works when
it's monic right I want there to be a
one out the front and there is not a one
at the moment okay so what should I do
to this to make that number at the front
one
I should divide right like this is a
multiplied by X square the opposite of
multiplication is division so I'm going
to take every single term and I'm going
to divide by a right now that will lead
me to some fractions which is not that
great but that's okay that's okay I can
still work with fractions just takes me
a little time so my next line was it
look like x squared because those eyes
of kids sword I'm gonna write that be on
a at the front and then I've got C on a
here that's still zero you're happy with
that okay I've made it monic but what's
my next thing usually with completing
the square
I want this me to a square right and I
get it out come over the other so I'm
going to go X ed+ be on a x equals and
I'll put all of those you okay with that
- see okay now once I've done that now
I'm ready to do this completing the
square business I've got to add a number
that X now what was that two-step
process I went through every time a
Harvard Square
a Harvard swear so when I have this I
get will not you know twice as big right
have be on to a exactly that's the
having step right it's a bit messy be
wait that's the Harley part and then
squaring is the squaring part okay I add
it to the left I better add it to the
right you're standing in Haven fantastic
okay
oh this looks messy but that's okay have
a little bit of faith
let's see what happens right over here
on the left now I've made this thing it
looks it looks like a disaster but it's
a perfect square right what is it a
perfect square of I'll give you a clue
it starts with an X short car right okay
look this they're all pluses so this
must be a plus right and what's this guy
going to be here it's gonna be be onto a
right cuz when I expand this guy it's
gonna become B on to a squared you see
that how that turns into that okay so
I've got my perfect square factor eyes
over there on the left on the right I've
got a pair of fractions okay so I want
to simplify this a little bit what's
this guy over here when I actually
Square him out the B turns into a B
squared what is the denominator turn
it's you be careful the to turn into do
a 4 and the a turns into a square so I'm
getting 4a squared over here the
right-hand side all right now I just
dealt with him the reason I wrote him
first is because you see how I have
another fraction when you add two
fractions together what you do I want to
cross both my so I get a common
denominator right that's what I really
want okay now at the moment it's - see
on a I want the denominator to look more
like this so how do I turn - see on a
how do I turn that a into for a squid
what do I multiply by for a so if I
multiply this by for a I better multiply
the top by 4a
are you ok with that see what I've done
so this fraction is this fraction
dressed up so I can add these two
together there's a plus sign there
okay let's Heather let's deal with this
right head side before I get rid of the
square root there's a minus term first
which is a bit weird and a plus term
second so let's just switch that order
around so I'm going to get b squared
minus 4ac are you happy with that just
written it in a sort of nice order and
the bottom by denominator is still 4a
squared that was the whole point
4a squared okay the it's still that
squared thing
okay I'm almost there I'm gonna consume
the right head cyclones what a stage
will I do I take the square root because
I want to get rid of the square okay so
on the left hand side the square is gone
although right I draw a big square root
sign I put everything on the right hand
side underneath it
and then there's one more thing I have
to do a root but there's not just one
square root there's two there's the plot
and there's the - okay there's always
two solutions there okay now we did a
lot of work here and it still looks
really messy but because me by yourself
I'm almost at this step where I've
solved the thing right I only have to do
a couple more things to get the X by
himself I want to get the B on to a on
the Left I wanna get him out the way
okay so I'm gonna write x equals and
because it's a plus B on to a I've got a
minus B on two away from both sides okay
so I've got a minus B on to a hand out
the front there and then I've got the
plus minus of this big square root thing
okay now just before I write down
something for this I want you to have a
think of a different example if I said
what's the square root of a number like
say oh I don't know
25 over 64 okay what would your answer
be to that question it would be 5 over 8
now the reason you have 5 & 8 is because
sort of without thinking about it you've
taken the square root of the top and
you've taken the square root of the
bottom which is 5 and 8 are you happy
with that now I can do the same thing
here you see I have a square root of a
fraction well the square root of a
fraction is a fraction of square roots
okay so I'm going to write that top part
with a square root and I'm going to
write the bottom part with a square root
are you okay with that yeah everything's
looking good okay now the reason why
that's so fantastically useful is
because minus B on to a plus or minus
this guy on the top what happens that
denominator what's the square root of 4a
squared
answer is 2a that's where I got it from
in the first place you remember that
look I squared threw away that game
before I squared so then I could go
backwards right that should just be ca
and magically now I have the same
denominator definitely yes you may
so now that I have the same denominator
for this pair of fractions I can whack
them together into one write x equals
and ready for it
take a deep breath minus B plus or minus
the square root of b squared minus 4ac
or to a exhale that that is the
quadratic what this thing means by
completing the square and it was a lot
of lines right it was a lot of lines
because there was a lot of algebra and I
couldn't simplify a lot of x equals band
so long as I know what a B you know and
you soon as you read the question right
for example here 1x squared minus X
minus 3 right the second I see that I
can go is well alright there more color
there's a there is there's a minus 1
there there's be that second coefficient
and there's the minus 3 don't the minus
sign by the way it matters okay let's
see what happens x equals minus B is
going to be just on because there's a
plus or minus the square root of B
squared what's B squared it's just gonna
be one again okay - for now what a and C
and C are 1 and minus 3 all right 1 and
minus 3 okay all over all over what 2 a
which in this case is 2 so now I just
need to simplify a bit write 1 plus or
minus the square root of okay minus 4
times minus 3 that's positive 12 right
so
one plus 12 all over two and then I say
that's 1 plus or minus the square root
of 13 on 2 now you might look at that
and sort of raise your eyebrow if you
caught on is that the same as that and
the answer is yeah it is because have a
look at this see this twos come out of
the square root it's not under a square
root sign that's because here I'll
finish this so that you can go here
that's the square root of remember I
actually said it 13 over 4 but that's
the square root of 13 on - do you
recognize it
it's the same thing